نشرت مجله التايم تقريرا يركز على الاطار
الزمني لما سماه حركه القوات الاسرائيليه
اذ ياتي قرار سحب الاف الجنود من غزه قبيل
زياره لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي للمنطقه
وبعد ان تجاوزت اداره بايدن للمره الثانيه
خلال شهر الكونغرس عبر الموافقه على تزويد
اسرائيل بشحنه جديده من الاسلحه جاء في
التقرير نقلا عن مسؤول امني اسرائيلي سابق
ان تغيير وضع ال قوات في غزه قد يكون
نتيجه للضغوط
الامريكيه اما في صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
فنجد تقريرا اخر يربط سحب جزء من القوات
الاسرائيليه المنخرط في حرب غزه بتزايد
الاعباء الاقتصاديه في اسرائيل على خلفيه
التعبئه القويه المستمره منذ اشهر وغياب
اي افق لانهاء الحرب في وقت قريب ويوضح
التقرير بالاشاره الى توقعات الخبراء
بانكماش الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي خلال عام
2024 تناولت صحيفه يدعو ت احرونوت قرار
بنك اسرائيل المركزي خفض سعر الفائده بشكل
مفاجئ كما تقول ومخالف للتوقعات بعد ان
تجنب اتخاذ الخطوه خلال السنوات الماضيه
كما ياتي القرار كنتيجه مباشره للحرب
المستمره وتزايد مخاوف رجال الاعمال من
زياده التضخم خصوصا في ظل التوترات التي
يفرضها الحوثيون في البحر الاحمر
رات الواشنطن بوست ان دخول الولايات
المتحده على خط المواجهه المسلحه في البحر
الاحمر من شانه ان يفاقم ازمه الشحن
البحري عبر العالم ويؤثر على الاقتصاد
العالمي الصحيفه تنقل عن خبراء في مجال
النقل البحري ان ما يحدث سيغير واقع الحال
في البحر الاحمر لافتين الى ان بواخر
الشحن كثيره جدا ومرافقه كل واحده منها
ببوار بحريه امر غير غير ممكن
عمليا في صحيفه هارس نقرا عن اباده
القنابل الاسرائيليه لعائلات فلسطينيه
باكملها منذ بدايه الحرب في غزه الصحيفه
ذكرت ان نحو 1800 عائله فقدت الكثير من
افرادها بسبب القصف المتواصل ثم تشرح بعض
الظروف الصعبه التي تضطر اغلب افراد
العائله في غزه الى العيش مجتمعين في منزل
واحد وعند النزوح يفرون غالبا الى اق
ومن الطبيعي وفق الصحيفه ان قصف مكان
وجودهم سيقتل الكثير ممن يحملون نفس اسم
العائله